the violence erupted early afternoon in
Trafalgar Square far-right activists had
hijacked a protest to protect statues
including that of Winston Churchill it's
not the majority of the crowd where I've
come from East Midlands miss by a few of
us there's trouble down were told not to
travel danced aboard the statues all
shoppers come with it's not words but
some of this lot hadn't really come to
protect anything they come for a fight
at points early on they clashed with
some of the black lives matter
protesters as police tried to keep the
peace
at one point both groups were in the
square black lives matter at the bottom
of the screen and police forming a
single line of protection between the
rival protesters missiles were thrown
between the two groups before they were
dispersed
the black lives matter group was mostly
massing in Hyde Park some of the
protesters have been just as disruptive
last weekend clashing with police and
vandalizing Churchill's statue
definitely not go home I will not be
intimidated by these fascists not be
intimidated by government either we are
here to stand for the people the job of
the police was to keep these two
movements apart so police have created a
sterile area down Whitehall beyond that
blockade is Trafalgar Square and that's
where the black lives matter group have
amassed and here is the group protecting
the statues you can see the whole of
Parliament Square has been blocked off
by police they told people not to come
to London the message was stay away and
clearly some people have ignored that
but they are fairly small in number the
violence distracted from more peaceful
prostatic protesters which included
veterans such as Tyrone Archer it's
Winston Churchill Sir Winston Churchill
and it doesn't any statues actually
important to me whether it's Nelson
Mandela or even a slave-trader statute
doesn't matter to me it's our history
that's what represents we wouldn't even
be here in this position right now if it
wasn't for them there were other
protests around the country including a
much more sedate affair in reading
walking down the street in a white lady
saw me and she crossed over the road and
held her back and that was quite
shocking for me especially when I had
the same bag but racism it's rife Navy
scene when I'm an adult and I have
children they won't have to go through
what I went through it was also a
demonstration in Brighton it was
peaceful
but tense there are legitimate issues at
stake here but one wonders - whether
some of this tension and anger is also
the steam rising out of months of
lockdown
Jason Farrell Sky News